i want to start after uh the gabon
report that we were playing there i just
want to gauge your view on the
philosophy really is it the
responsibility of richer nations to be
helping developing nations with their
climate change goals magic what do you
think 100 yes and i'll explain
it it's firstly important to recognize
that the climate crisis is hugely unjust
like throughout the 19th and 20th
centuries countries like the uk and
those in the global north were and still
are some of the biggest
the world's biggest emitters of carbon
pollution as a direct result have become
some of the world's wealthiest nations
let's be frank that's it's largely
happened at the expense of developing
countries such as gabon in the global
south and as a result of issues like
colonial and post-colonial and relations
so countries like the uk and other kind
of more advanced countries and in europe
i've got a moral obligation to
compensate those countries and
communities that are negatively impacted
by climate change due to our let's our
collective failure to tackle reasonable
steps to limit our emissions in the past
as well and as today because it's going
to take a global approach to it rather
than just individual approaches so a big
yes from you imagine what about you zaya
well i have to agree with madget there i
know that rich countries are
disproportionately responsible for
climate emissions and that poor
countries are disproportionately
impacted by climate change and so
obviously there's a debt to be paid from
rich countries to poor countries but
there's a way of going about that
there's good models and bad models
morocco and what's happening with the
green climate fund as an example of a
good model perhaps we can talk about
that but one thing that i want to point
out if you consider something like
losing weight as an analogy for lowering
emissions right now what the rich
countries are saying is hey we want to
eat all the ice cream and we want the
poor countries to do all the diet and
exercise it's all going to balance out
on the books but the question is you
have to say hey is this fair b even if
those poorer countries get fit they
can't continue on that treadmill if the
emissions continue to rise fundamentally
what needs to happen is that the rich
countries have to lower their emissions
and their resource use if you want to
see that real change they have to stop
eating that proverbial ice cream yeah i
mean you mentioned that and i just i
just want to bring in this quote here
because this really speaks uh to the
issue doesn't it uh here we go and
really when you've got the the richer
nations um enjoying the economic growth
um that has come as a consequence of
damaging the planet and then they're
expecting developing countries
to do their bit i mean we're
talking about a lift there for african
nations what does that lift look like
magic what do you think
well we need to unlock funds and
resources to developing countries that
are affected by and years and legacies
of extraction and exploitation and i
think a really good first step and an
essential one towards repairing and this
as well as historic injustices and
saving our planets is for countries in
the global north who are and i'll keep
repeating it responsible for this crisis
is to immediately engage in a
wide-ranging program of debt
cancellation towards developing
countries so us to at least break one
link in that long history of extractive
exploitation the cop26 really gives us a
great opportunity to do that yeah and
zai what do you think imagine proposing
their debt cancellation does that work
well i think that there's ways that you
can work with local countries so that
you're not imposing your ideas on
another sovereign nation
and making them develop like an old
1980s development models what i like
about what morocco and the green uh the
green climate fund what they're doing
right now if i could share with you for
an instance in morocco they have argan
trees and these argan trees have been
harvested for millennia they produce the
nuts that make the oil for my hair but
it's also a great food source the
forests there are a buffer for
desertification uh for the sahara desert
so right now those forests are suffering
from over harvesting and climate change
but what the fund is doing is they are
building tens of thousands of hectares
of argan uh of orchards and so what
that's going to do is that's going to be
an extra buffer for desertification it
protects the natural forest and also
it's going to be a a sequestering device
500 000 tons of additional carbon being
sequestered by the trees but best of all
it helps the local economies and the
women in particular who have
cooperatives who've been doing this
traditional way of life with harvesting
the nuts and producing oil as an end
effect i get some argan oil for my
shampoo but fundamentally what we have
to do when we do this sort of transfer
of wealth is we have to consult with
local countries and we have to do things
that are to their benefit first
you